there's no time o clock hey everybody
its episode 131 that's right and this is
a ghost story show yes yeah that's in
the rotation now well like I said I'd
like to do a paranormal try on
paranormal sure go like like mix it up a
little bit so we're not doing the same
thing all the time
yeah now this was actually and I'm I'm
glad and I can't remember I feel really
bad like I'm super disorganized so you
know don't hate but I can't remember you
recommended this cuz it's a long time
ago but somebody recommended we do
Mackinac Island yeah and I'm really glad
you suggested because I had never heard
of it even though it's apparently like
this super [ __ ] haunted I like every
place on it is haunted pretty much
yeah and I'd never heard of it I'm
surprised you invertebrate creation no I
lived in Michigan for a few years yeah
in the down river area I did like two
years of high school there yeah in place
called Trenton Michigan yeah just right
near where Eminem came from I think he
was from like South Gate or something
like that yeah Michigan is its own place
it's quite cool in some ways but in
other ways it's kind of boring then I
moved up to Detroit and I was there for
about a year this is second when wet
second West Hancock at a place called
wet at the Wellesley which is an
apartment building yes stone yeah man I
was like Mad Max Ville well you said you
lived there during like The Crow era
yeah during the Crower I lived there I
lived in the Wellesley for like six
months and then I lived in a in a
renovated rebuilt cattle slaughterhouse
I've always wanted to do that you always
see it in movies but I've never but you
actually lived in yeah I could drive my
car into the cattle elevator
get up to the third floor where my
partner was department doesn't make any
damn sense
just as it wasn't an apartment now
somehow
you couldn't you couldn't really heat it
and when winter came boys cold as hell
yeah yeah goth girls from the shelter
and [ __ ] where if I can staying over
there with me every night
keeping you warm not really they weren't
keeping you warm it seemed like I was
there forever but I really was it was
that time in your life when you're just
out of high school yeah everything seems
like forever and everything seems
because you're like 18 19 and the month
seems like a year yeah cuz you're cuz
you have it weird oh no time diet
compression it's like time compression
disorder when you're young you know
that's probably only there for about
four or five months see about a year
it's funny because every now and then
like I'll read something from somebody
that's like some little baby aged like
23 or something
and they'll say something like oh you
know I should be married I'm so old and
stuff like that I'm like holy crap dude
it's like I could be your Wow
me and you have known each other for
nearly 10 years ignite years now yeah
seems like yesterday
it really doesn't at the time when a
year seems like a year now when you when
you're your 40s a year seems like I'll
have couple months yeah like as soon as
you get I don't really remember when
time started to accelerate yeah but it
was sometime in my probably my mid-30s I
think it's June and then like you'll be
talking about something it's like oh the
other day I was doing this that was four
years four years ago yeah and like I
said we've known each other yeah we were
talking about it we were walking the
other day is like I've known you for
nine years we've been together almost
eight years some pictures from pictures
from the past came up in our Facebook
yeah you know minutes at nine years ago
it was me and you at the club with some
other people I was like nine years ago
what [ __ ] that's not allowed yeah
yesterday you know hey kids we don't
live long we just don't yeah you're born
it seems like it takes forever you do
some [ __ ] in between like a sandwich
filling then
all sudden you go [ __ ] I'm 30 yeah I go
down and then like [ __ ] I'm 40
oh [ __ ] I'm 50 I can't believe that yeah
I think that's what I understand was
talking about when he's talking about
relativity
yeah you just raced towards death that's
cheerful that's something you raced
towards them you do kind of though like
I said it's like because I remember yeah
I remember like when I was in my early
20s being like oh god I'm so old and
everything but blah and then like that's
six months from now I'll never make good
yeah but then like from 30 to 40 was
like super quick and then 40 and now I'm
like 46
yeah and that seemed like nothing yeah
it seems like a couple days ago
seriously and it's like I you know I
know a lot of people say that to you but
yeah I was like 40 and I'm a time oldest
[ __ ] dude that was like yesterday
yeah I look at the mirror though and I
see some difference but it's not as bad
as I thought it was gonna be yeah I kind
of feel where the kitty cats moving the
camera what you moving caring for okay
she likes to be I'll move it out of the
way why don't you be on the show instead
of being behind the camera she's got to
have a place to leave you're cuter than
we are you should be on camera instead
of us if you could talk we could put you
on the show okay so we were talking my
getting old anyway
we gotta get this [ __ ] show rolling
we have shoutouts and things to talk
about you also have your your games yeah
games are done yeah we're gonna do some
shout outs before we get started talking
about okay Mackinac Island and all oh is
that okay my other computer just like
popped on because it does that
periodically poltergeist we're getting
rid of that thing I'm telling you
well yeah I got to get a new one yeah
pretty soon so yeah at this point uh you
know like I said before we're recording
more shows ahead of time so it's kind of
harder for me to gauge but if I'm
slurring my words just because I've been
drinking working all day yeah cuz this
is this is not the first recording we've
done so if he starts getting incoherent
you'll know why I mixed it too strong I
really did but I'm all wrong you did
that like accidentally
with bunny rabbit ears yeah I see I know
how you do this is that Hornitos yeah he
got the good [ __ ] this morning just cuz
I was paying yeah I guess you were like
hey are you good [ __ ] yeah that's like
ten dollars we were buying it
we were rotating I've you bought my
vocal about the vodka last even though
my vodka is only $14 no but it was the
other [ __ ] we had to go we had my bagels
because I'm we had to go buy bagels
where were not treat cat treats yeah
that's all this little brat will eat you
know what I mean that's so we have to go
to Sam to get like the three babies
those temptation cat treats that's all
she wants to eat but we got us some
fries dries girl she's regular food
sheets like freeze-dried what are they
minnows minnows and she like little
freeze-dried pieces of fish and stuff
she takes those yeah but yeah so uh what
was I gonna say okay so by the time this
comes out faceless villain one as I said
I rerecorded it yeah so that should be
up by the time this show goes up because
it's almost finished by this important
when it's not maybe we'll do an
announcement in the stream we'll see
we'll see yeah but yeah by the time this
comes out faceless film which should be
re-recorded like I said it's it's not
hugely different it's just the audio
quality is better private I mean yeah so
if you were like hesitant about getting
it before cuz you were like oh maybe the
audio is not good or something like that
it's much better now there's only a
couple of people complained about it
though but really you know I don't want
any complaints so that's what I mean
it's I mean faceless villain to some one
of our normal subscribers who got who
bought that yeah if you'd it said there
was a market difference yeah and we got
a much better microphone I gotta get E
now yeah you don't and you you just
don't have to do as much engineering and
[ __ ] afterwards you can basically roll
with that a little bit of sound
reduction and that's it
yeah because honestly when I recorded
the ship before with our other
microphone and we didn't have a terrible
microphone before it's like it wasn't
like a buck 51 or anything like that but
just was you had to do so much to it
yeah
like to make it sound halfway decent and
we didn't have the dead room then so
true so yeah that kind of
- um so yeah that should be up also if
you didn't see our last movie review it
was Lucci a bull cheese city of the
Living Dead so go check that out as part
of his gates of Hell trilogy we also did
the Beyond and I probably will do house
of the past by the cemetery at some
point also shout outs to our newest
patrons and like I said yeah this should
hear because well because we're um doing
more shows at once and like doing them
ahead like I feel kind of bad because I
can't give like shout outs to patrons as
it happens as it happens like I'm gonna
have to like store them up but in the
past few weeks we have had some new
patrons so we're gonna say hello to our
new patrons Maximilian and Eric and
Daniel yeah whoo holy [ __ ] dude we got
some people just mentioned you there's a
20 in there and I think there's this a
five in there too but you know we have a
several $20 a month patrons but we've
got our first $50 a month patron I have
a purpose because that is [ __ ]
awesome yeah that's really cool we you
know we also have some contributors that
will send us just out of the blue like a
hundred on PayPal PayPal yes and we had
a person called Melanie a girl called me
when they do that recently so thank you
very much that and like I said um I know
that some people have been talking about
the patreon and like have they been
having problems recently yeah yeah so if
you don't want to do patreon I mean go
to our blog 13 o'clock podcast dot
WordPress comm there's a link in the
sidebar and I'm actually and it might
already be done by the time the show
goes up I'm actually going to set up a
button where if you want to give a
monthly donation from PayPal right then
you can do that as well or you can just
give a one-time donation it doesn't
matter and let me expand on that a
little bit the owner of patreon came out
and said patreon was unsustainable that
spooked a lot of people okay so if you
guys wanna leave patreon there's some
people that don't want to
till patreon for free speech issues and
[ __ ] like that that's been on in the
past or whatever you can do you can you
can substitute
through PayPal yeah
and the in they have it's just like
patreon really there's no big difference
the main difference is is that PayPal
takes less yeah so if you give this you
take a percentage a taking on cents but
they take less yeah so if you want to
give us a dollar a month do that on
PayPal yeah okay cuz I PayPal you only
take 10%
I don't remember something like that it
might not even be that much thank you
Dad much might be though three and you
can do a monthly thing will give you
will give you the same perks that we
give patreon supporters ya know points
you not I mean at the certain pay levels
yeah we'll do the same will match that
on on patreon yes beyond paper although
like I said we're still giving like for
the patreon people they get early access
yeah that's what hey that's why I could
you know I could do it to people to give
me a PayPal but I need their email
address yeah we might been working a few
little I could partner but yeah we could
do would be a lot to keep track of but I
could do it yeah so you know it's like I
said if you don't like patreon then we
have a PayPal account there's another
one out there called subscribe star and
we don't really have a subscribed star
account as of now I might get on that
but we may get on them yeah it's good to
have to be diversified yeah and you know
like I said we appreciate anything that
anybody can do and like you know we love
that you guys love the show and it's
like that's like really cool we didn't
really think anybody would listen to us
yeah we're on to run [ __ ] shoot what
else we are I used to put them on
dailymotion but I stopped doing it and
then you know it seems like [ __ ] shoot
is probably mostly the other one then
like I don't know [ __ ] shootout we
actually have a lot of hits on BET shoot
yeah they're getting bigger I don't give
any comments on there though no it has a
weird commenting system on it has a
weird lots of system yeah I don't I
don't like the lack of keywords
it's a new it's all what hashtags it's a
new compete competing platform it made
an here so it's just good to to you know
to get on it when we can but I think
[ __ ] you will survive and honestly if
anybody's listening on a [ __ ] shoot
it's like does the [ __ ] come up because
here's what was happening and I somebody
contacted me on Twitter about this that
they're like hey I think you forgot to
put this one on [ __ ] shoot and I was
kind of like well here's the problem I
was putting [ __ ] on YouTube and then
putting on [ __ ] shoot like manually and
then every time I would go back to [ __ ]
you in there twice it would be up there
twice and I'd be like what the [ __ ] is
going on and then I figured out when I
put something like I put our patreon
video just on YouTube and I didn't put
it on [ __ ] shoot but it came up on
[ __ ] shoot anyway so it turns out that
[ __ ] shoot was automatically putting my
[ __ ] from YouTube on our bit Chooch and
they were somehow linked so yeah well
they did ask me to put in my channel
identification so it was obviously like
putting up stuff so now I don't manually
put stuff on bit shoot anymore because
apparently it's just cuz I'm on there
automatically which is fine with me
because that's one less thing you me to
do but yeah I was confused for a long
time it's like why is there two of
everything well when we filled out that
stuff for [ __ ] shoot it asked what your
channel was here and evidently it kind
of hooked it up so you you automatically
post on both now which I guess it does
because seems to I mean when I put [ __ ]
on YouTube it automatically comes up on
Twitter used to automatically come up on
Google+ although they're getting rid of
Google+ cuz nobody's on that [ __ ]
anymore I never went on it either I just
push it on there automatically but yeah
so YouTube was just so convenient it's
been around for so and everybody's on it
everybody knows YouTube so it's like
it's it's kind of hard to compete I
think they all kind of have half-life
something will take place something will
take its place eventually
well eventually that's just not time I
don't think it's now we're gonna run
mostly YouTube until you know Tilford
the mode yeah yeah now the only other
shatter and a half before we get to
talking about talking about the ghost
stories if you remember like I don't
even remember like how long ago it was
but I was talking about how I have a
little another side gig
I didn't have enough already but I have
one on the game crafter called giallo
games and I design board and card games
that are based around like GL and movies
gel and movie tropes that type of stuff
I think I showed you guys this one
before which is called a crimson drop on
a crimson on a Crystal palette which is
kind of like a clue style game but more
like jello based it's like said in Italy
and you can have like all different
adventures and all different mysteries
and stuff like that it also has an
expansion pack which has like what looks
like a nap
what has like more locations and stuff
like that well I can just show you some
of the cards they're all in a bag but um
I'm trying to work on more but it's you
know kind of hard and when you get when
you like order the see it's like all
kind of where's the camera okay there it
is camera yeah so see there's that card
games yeah it's like a card kids love it
the kids love card games yeah but yeah
so I have those so I put up a new one
this one is called the cursive names of
nightmares this is actually a game it's
just a card game and it's one where you
kind of come up with there's all these
cards in there that have like words that
are sort of used in jello movie titles
like colors and animals and stuff and
numbers and stuff like that and what
you're supposed to do is kind of like
take the cards that you have and like
put together the best title that you
have and then come up with a pitch like
for a movie that goes along with it and
like best one wins so that's this game
and this one just went on sale so look
out for that so it has there's this
that's the main game and then there's
also an expansion pack called gore
galore which has like a lot of kind of
more bloody kind of words I don't
understand it I don't want to get it how
does it work it's like it's kind of like
I don't really know these card
games it's not my thing you know it's a
little bit similar it's a little bit
similar to like cards against humanity'
type thing right or actually there's one
called schmoovy
okay it's actually pretty similar to
that you get a hand of cards and then
you pick out the best ones you like you
you invent like a title of a giallo
okay from the cards that you have all
right cuz they each have like a word on
them that's very like giallo
there's like score involved yeah and
then like you come up with a movie like
a plot synopsis like of the movie and
then like you pitch it and then whoever
is doing the deciding that round they
you know they'll pick the best one is
there something you can do when you drop
um sure okay you sent the beer board
games oh yeah I was honestly that's kind
of like they're the ones that kind of
got me into back into designing board
games like watching beer and board games
cuz I was like oh yeah it's like well
the blame society that's like the hold
they have a whole bunch of shows but
that's what got me interested back in
like design and games again so that
would be that's like my worry like where
can they buy those go to the game
crafter calm not just game crafter it's
the game crafter calm and look up giallo
games like I said I haven't nothing in
the description I have another one done
it's just that before you can put them
on sale you have to buy a copy and I
haven't been able to like afford to buy
a copy of the third one because it's
kind of expensive because it's like a
big like board get like a like a build
as you go like board game it's called
the three Saurez and so if I but these
ones I did so I have a copy of each of
these so they are you buy the other one
yeah yeah that's how they do cuz you
have to proof it right so that's how
they roll
well the packaging is great on it
there's little graphics and everything
the cards waited yeah she did a great
job well thank you that's I enjoy doing
that that's like fun for me that's like
my that's using my graphic design powers
for good except that I like what you've
used it for evil
I might have oh I did
yeah okay I'm gonna tell this story
right here even though we'll get to the
good stories in a minute I promise
yeah so I know okay so I used to live in
Clearwater which if you didn't know it
was like sighing okay so I used to work
for a company it wasn't like a
Scientology based company it was
actually like a business-to-business
like insurance sales kind of crap it was
like Direct Mail and I worked there as a
graphic designer it was owned by
Scientologists and probably about 75% of
the people that worked there were
Scientologists so because they there
were other there were a few other
graphic designers there too but for
whatever reason like the manager of the
department asked me to do she's like hey
can you do like this kind of outside
project you know we'll give you extra
money and blah blah blah and I was like
sure extra money that's awesome cuz you
know I hated everybody's money yeah so I
ended up designing this stuff and it
ended up being covers for textbooks for
the Scientology schools okay so I'm
sorry
I feel really bad I feel bad that like I
designed like the covers of textbooks
that would be used to indoctrinate
children into Scientology because I am a
terrible terrible chorus line so see I
have like your making my hair like it's
well it's a sliding scale and it's kind
of like Third Reich is like 10
Scientology might be so it's like kind
of its kind of evil kind of evil okay
but I'm just saying I'm admitting that
right now I still feel really bad about
it you know as many years ago job is a
job is a job true I did they don't have
any reach anyway yeah that's at least
now everybody thinks they're ridiculous
so I feel like less people falling for
it I just still feel bad for everybody
knows what that is they get born into it
all right so let's get to the main
topics we are talking about Mackinac
Island which like I said even though I
kind of know a lot about OHS you know
how most haunted places blah blah I had
never heard of this place which is
strange because it's pretty
an entire island it's not a big island
but it's an entire island that pretty
much every place on it is said to be
haunted you know what I mean yeah I
can't really picture where this is it's
in Lake Huron like you're on ok yes how
far from the coast of Lake Huron I think
it's about 20 okay now the interesting
thing about Mackinac Island is that it's
um really there's there's only about 500
people live there like all the time but
in the summer like spring and summer
months it's like this huge tourist
destination because most of it like 80%
of the island is like a national park
and it's actually the second oldest
national park in the US after
Yellowstone so in case you're ever on
Jeopardy and they ask you yeah you know
and what they did on this island it's
only like it's less than four square
miles this island and what they did on
the island was one if you build on the
island you have to make it look like
it's pretty much all just like Victorian
looking you can't make anything modern
looking everything has to be like old
looking also there are no motorized
vehicles allowed except for emergency
vehicles and snowmobiles in the
wintertime so no cars no nothing so it's
all rosin in time yeah so it basically
if you see pictures of it it looks like
an old Victorian town like building no
motor vehicles it must be pretty small
it is very small like I said it's only
four square miles okay
and yeah so the history this place like
I said because it's you know every place
and it is hard and stuff like that and I
know how everyone says India beargrass
publoc but this one could all Indian
vary over this one super was like for
real
going all the way back to poltergeist
yeah which were yeah we'll probably do
like we're probably gonna do a movie
actually Indian burial grounds go back
to a medieval [ __ ] right isn't that
when they started when did that trope
come when did that trope appear when
was the first incident explanation
because I feel like poltergeist was
probably the highest you know like or
the best known instance of that right
but I don't remember if there was one
there had to be a matter it doesn't
matter it's connected but yeah but this
is actually an Indian burial ground
burial ground because this island
because of its location in Lake Huron it
was kind of like a strategic location
now they have found like archeologists
have gone through and everything like
that and they found the Native American
I believe it was the Ojibwa tribe have
been there since about 900 AD they found
like arrowheads and stuff like that like
dating back to that time and actually
the name of the island it's weird
because it's spelled like it should be
pronounced mack and nack like it ends
with the sea but it's actually
pronounced Mackinac and the original
Native American name was Miss lahmacun
oo which actually means a great turtle
because that's kind of what they thought
that the island looked like like they've
got like a big turtle right so the so
Native Americans were living on this
island like about 700 years before the
Europeans came and they were using it as
good because they thought that it was
kind of like I guess because of its
particular location or whatever they
were using it as like a tribal burial
ground for like their chieftains and
chieftains and okay I didn't really live
on it they did but right okay because
they called it four square miles is
nothing yeah there can't be much what
happens they thought it was like the
home of the Great Spirit pretty much you
know because I don't think four square
miles could support much of a biosphere
you um Tom oh right you wouldn't have
any deer on something that small you
couldn't support a big population yeah
you'd have to fish for a living that'd
be really the only way you could get
meat I've heard there's good fishing on
this [ __ ] though yeah
and a lot of people go there like I said
less than 500 people live on this island
year-round because in the winter it gets
cold as [ __ ] and that's the only way you
get there is like a ferry or like a
little plane um cuz it free you know the
lake freezes over like in the winter
pretty much but in the summer they get
like 15,000 visitors a day so they
winter come over there so in the winter
that the lake freezes over you could
walk out to the island yeah I wonder if
you could and so but probably nobody
does late miles is nothing yeah well
here's the thing like and I'm gonna
mention this right here our favorites
the ghost hunters Oh an episode about
well they did it an episode about
Mackinac Island but they only visited
one place on it because like I said a
bunch of places on here supposed to be
haunted
they only visited one place I think they
went to the mission point resort or the
Grand Hotel the hotel I can't really
remember right now cuz I watched it was
on dailymotion and the thing that I
remember most about that because nothing
ever happens on these [ __ ] episodes
they just go and they wander around in
their [ __ ] green light they're just
like did you hear that ah yeah you know
what I mean it's basically all like that
so the only thing I remember was that
they came they went to the island in the
wintertime so like no one was there and
they were like well we're not sure if
the ferry is gonna be it's like running
today we'll run you over the island but
we're not sure it's gonna be run
tomorrow cuz might be frozen it's too
dangerous blah blah blah so you might
have to come back by plane now one of
the members of the ghost hunters was so
afraid of flying and I get that I don't
like flying either but he was like well
I'm just gonna have to stay here then
because I'm not getting on a [ __ ]
everything and it's like well I get that
but if it was a choice between like I'll
fly if I have to I'm not going that far
where I'm just like well I'll just
[ __ ] swim back I'm just imagine this
little island though yeah four square
miles it's cool looking and it's got
Victorian houses on it yeah it's cool
okay is there a power plant on it how do
they how do they get electricity to I
don't know they do maybe they've run a
lot
now - it's only 20 miles yeah it's not
far like from the mainland as far as I
can determine they have a ferry run
telephone lines to it okay
now the story goes that by the time the
European settlers arrived the mid 6:16
OS that all the Native Americans had
[ __ ] off Oh [ __ ] off and oh yeah or
you know they just left the cemeteries
there now look at baby cookie back there
what are you doing she's yeah you gotta
wait by the way we found we found out
come here baby could come here everybody
see when we got baby cookie a Brazilian
woman told us that that she found it in
her backyard with the dogs and fitness
tail off yeah rosewood very roll with
that
wait we believe that I lived in Brazil
she's embarrassed yeah she's which
claims to be mm-hmm
growing up in Brazil in certain times
anything my high school life I spent two
years there I went back later Sao Paulo
Brazil you know I speak Portuguese
everything for those of you don't know
but I know that sometimes a Brazilian I
love Brazilians you know Brazilians if
they don't know something they'll just
tell you a story okay cuz that's better
than just say it's better than just say
they didn't know that's a Manx that's
that cat's tail wasn't bitten off I was
sitting there touching touching the end
of that tail and I was like that seems
natural yeah and then we're talked about
it and we looked up a Manx and all the
features of the Manx physical and
psychological features of a Manx that's
a [ __ ] Manx well here's the thing we
thought that she was a weirdo
ya know everything not a bad weirdo but
like she her behavior is very strange
for a cat cuz I've had a lot of cats in
my lifetime
yeah and she has a much different
personality than most cats that I've had
yeah but when we were like well maybe
she's a Manx and maybe that woman just
made that [ __ ] up about a dog biting off
her tail and maybe her talk the hair
tail is just stumpy naturally so we
started looking up Manx like behavioural
character in the writer that's her
that's exactly
what she sounds like yeah jacked up back
rear rear end long yeah that back
shortly like a bowling ball with legs on
it
Rocco ears Romney mangers make trill
voice very vocal practical joker just
yeah that's you know that's exactly just
more like a puppy than a cat
yeah dual coat yep so that's you know
and they don't get big yeah she's almost
two and she looks like a baby he's still
very little she still looks like a
kitten they don't get full-grown until
five years but yeah so we found out that
baby cookies a Manx yeah that's why
she's always wants to get out she's a
hunting cat yeah barn cat we had
wondered about that it is funny because
he said to her the other day it's like
we just thought you were weird but it
turns out that's just the way you walk
yeah so we're just like accepting yeah
if you got mad at what we just did we
have so many subscribers and so many
subscribers want you to show about
nothing about cats just cats
we had a rabbis to do an episode about
our kitty yeah yeah maybe we should
there's a lot of cat fans we have a lot
of female subscribers they love cats and
they love cats I don't know your problem
baby cookie jumps up in the camera all
the time so she's kind of a guest star I
know I wish you would jump up in the
camera morons like farting around behind
the lab session on stuff you guys oh no
look it daddy's got you
yeah see that's baby cookie what's up
what's up little one okay look at your
little okay yeah so okay so by the time
the European settlers got here like I
said Native Americans were gone off the
island so the story goes all [ __ ] off
they had all [ __ ] off as I said yeah
and the the island went under like a lot
of different ownership I believe like
the French like owned at first because
it was a very like strategic position so
like a lot of people wanted it because
it was like
right in the middle of Lake Huron and it
was like a really good position like
particularly for the fur trade and stuff
like that um so then like during the
French and Indian War the British got
hold of it and actually during the
Revolutionary War it was actually a
British stronghold and then it kind of
became like a bone of contention between
like British American forces during the
war 1812 because the Americans wanted it
as well so it was a lot of battles on
this particular island 1815 the island
finally went to the US you know finally
for after the Treaty of Ghent so this
island has a very interesting history
like I said it is actually a Native
American burial ground and there were a
lot of battles on there a lot of people
died on this particular island and stuff
like that so you know as I said a lot of
buildings on this are considered super
haunted and they're actually too many
like a bunch of the [ __ ] that I read
about it says it's like more dead people
on it than living people like more
ghosts on it than living people so it's
kind of a case where every single
there's a fort on it there's hotels on
it there's cottages on it every single
thing is pretty much awesome what you're
talking about is a little bitty island
yeah four square miles yeah it's a
cemetery with 500 people living on it
pretty much right and pretty much though
everywhere on it is said to be so what
you so you can go ahead and say that you
know if a place could be haunted because
it's a cemetery this would be a highly
likely place for yeah hauntings to
happen and it's not just the cemetery
there was also like battles and [ __ ]
like that happened to you and there was
some witchcraft [ __ ] there was all kind
of [ __ ] okay so we're gonna get into
that so yeah okay we're just back from a
break we had to get some bagels
we took a bagel break yeah man is hungry
we're drinking all this booze and
everything we you know we gotta soak it
up yeah man
bagels and cream cheese get a look at a
bunch of it okay we're gonna start
talking about what was actually reported
on Mac well like I said there are so
many different locations I can't even go
into all the [ __ ] Oh
but I will go into like the main places
that are said to be haunted on Mackinac
Island because there are several so
let's start with Fort Mackinac now this
fort was originally put there by the by
the British this was during the French
and Indian War okay so we're talking
about 1600s 17 16 1700 s I think is
before the Revolution yeah now at the
time it didn't see combat particularly
but um the Americans got the fort in
1783 after the Treaty of Paris and there
was like all kind of like squabbling
over and stuff like that now it wasn't
so much that there was like battles and
[ __ ] like that but there was a hospital
on the same kind of grounds as the fort
it's still there today you can still see
it so there was a hospital there the
British supposedly according to legend
murdered 72 Native Americans on the site
also so that might have contributed but
in the hospital evidently a lot of
people died of like tuberculosis typhoid
fever including many children of
soldiers that were stationed there and
apparently these children still haunt
the area there was actually a dungeon
also it was called the black hole at
least one prisoner died there in
captivity so that person was also and I
love this but the the soldier well okay
there was a other than the black hole
thing there was a soldier that fought
with another sounds like and like shot
him like during an argument you do the
soldiers name was James Brown not that
[Laughter]
see that's that's what I was hoping
would happened that you do like the
James Brown because he doesn't do that
right
like I was having that happen because
like James Brown needs a hot summer but
yeah so so that hole should happen now
is there any proof of these like I said
well look this is the legend yeah okay
everything I'm saying these just go
stories man don't don't watch much out
all right so most of the reports of the
hauntings at Fort Mackinac have to do
with a lot of people are reported
hearing like laughing or giggling but
it's usually like children so this would
probably like tie back to like all the
little kids that supposedly died there
during typhoid fever tuberculosis
outbreaks wetland you know this stuff
like that because like the kids that
were you know the soldiers kids that
died in the hospital that was on the
property so that was the whole thing
going there so there's like a lot of
laughter a lot of people reported that
other people have reported some like
poltergeist type activity moving
furniture kind of sliding around
furniture moving around or things moving
around setting off motion alarms and
like there's nothing obviously the roads
are nicely any dates and locations for
when this was happening and where whose
house pretty much all the time like I
said this this this island is kind of a
thing where it just seems like constant
[ __ ] is report according to the reports
yeah and like I said it's it's so many
locations that I had to just like narrow
it down to like a few major ones because
otherwise we'd be here all day like
talking about hey this little house on
the island said they have this it's
pretty much all the same type of
activity that's reported but it's like
all different like it's all over the
island okay like I I pretty much feel
like every place on this island has
reports of hauntings like I said it's
not a big place okay now let me stop for
a second okay when we say reports of
hauntings was there anything specific
like a certain person at this date
report
an occurrence to this association or are
we talking about a legendary just kind
of like general stories of everything
happening everywhere well as far as like
I said it's there's just so many yeah I
couldn't really narrow it down okay you
know and a lot of paranormal groups have
been to this place and have reported in
you know have reported activity in
various places like a 30 years yeah like
Ghost Hunters went there but they only
went to one place okay and that's like
one of the more haunted locations but
like I said you know there are a bunch
of places on here that are supposedly
haunted all right so I was surprised
that they only went to one place now
there is one guy on YouTube I camera
what his name is right now but I watched
a bunch of his videos but he went to
Mackinac Island and he went to a bunch
of different places that were supposedly
because he's like making a documentary
okay and he put like little bits of it
like up on YouTube so you can like watch
him there like 10 20 minutes so he goes
to like various locations which is
better than the ghost hunters ones
because they only went to one place and
like I said you know how Ghost Hunters
is seems do to actually be trying to do
an investigation yeah okay and I found
that like more interesting even though
it's kind of truncated because like I
said he's you know he's making a whole
documentary and he's just like having
our past experience with ghost hunter
programs their entertainment they're
just trying to knock out a show oh yeah
he's incompleted yeah I can understand
it I understand you're in a time crunch
yeah yeah budgetary limitations yeah
to do a true investigation would take
time you'd have to have somebody who
basically lived on the site because
phenomenon when phenomena actually does
happen which I've seen I've seen
phenomenon myself I believe it's just
that it's it's very sporadic you can't
the spontaneous you can't predict it
you'd have to live in that in an area
for a long period of time yeah in order
to actually get something or to see
something yourself and actually capture
something on film and v2 it's just
I kind of feel like that's kind of the
problem with shows like go centers and
stuff like that is because I mean and
you know no ding on them it's just that
they're trying to produce a show it's
like we have to go to this location we
can only be there for over within this
timeframe and if they don't then they
might be I'm not saying they do this but
I'm saying they might be kind of know
they're good well we're gonna like make
some stuff up like hey no we're gonna
get a cameraman hey make some noise back
there what was that right was that oh
because nothing's had what oh I know
what it said yeah so I kind of feel like
a lot of that might be going on and like
I said you know the show that they did
and I think the episode was called
frozen in fear where they went to
Mackinac Island but they only went to
one location on it which I can see that
okay they had to like focus it on one
place you know cuz like I said they
couldn't go everywhere but it seemed
like yeah they got some noises they got
a couple of like kind of vague EVPs and
the guy freaking about flying in a plane
that's kind of all I remember but they
didn't like good any other places they
did not as far as I know they did not go
to Fort Mackinac which is what I'm
talking about right now you could but
like I said Fort Mackinac you know
usually what's reported little kids
giggling little kid kind of noises
there's also other kind of stuff like
lights flashing on and on off and on
furniture moving around you get some
[ __ ] like babies crying that kind of
stuff
there's also a cemetery that's like
adjacent to the fort where like a lot of
the soldiers are you know other people
died that that were buried there and
sometimes it has been reported that they
saw a ghostly woman crying at one of the
graves okay so that's been reported also
cold spots you know your regular stuff
orbs which you know I don't give much
credence to orbs but I'm just gonna
mention that because that dust particles
now or have I been shown every arrives
it does
it looks like dust or a bug that's all
it ever looks like it doesn't ever look
like anything inexplicable no but um
something else that's been ruined this
was kind of interesting because like I
said there's an old hospital there and
evidently some people that died there
various diseases or whatnot now some
people have claimed to have seen piles
of phantom limbs and sometimes this
comes out on pictures although yeah I've
never seen one you all sure where I've
never seen a picture of them if you have
one please show it to me about that
creepy idea but it is yeah it is weird
that like several people have reported
that they went into this like old
hospital that's like a ruin or whatever
and they saw like piles of phantom limbs
there so that's kind of creepy um also
kind of stuff like you know just you
know random kind of [ __ ] kids laughing
music that kind of stuff you know
Mackinaw that's Fort Mackinac yeah
what's it look like did you see a
photograph yeah I'll put a photo up in
the video
I got yeah it's pretty big okay I got
photos of most of the major places cuz
like I said this is a huge like tourist
destination so there's all kind of
pictures of it all over the Internet if
you want to look it up um so you know
but like I said poltergeist activity
like ship being rearranged all that kind
of [ __ ] um some people have said too
that the EVPs that they captured were in
the like in various Native American
languages so there's that too um okay so
the next place I want to talk about on
Mackinac Island that supposedly hot is
the Mission Point Resort and now I think
if I remember correctly that this is
where the Ghost Hunters people went to
now this place was actually it was first
established as a missionary school in
1827 for the children of mixed-race
European and Native American children so
you know teaching them about
Christianity and whatnot so that was how
it started its life and then in the
1950s this
evangelist group took it over and this
evangelist group was called the moral
realignment ya gonna realize tomorrow
like I read that and I just laughed and
laughed I must see if that must have
something to do with changing Catholics
to Protestants how much I bet something
like that I guess I'm not really sure
yeah moral rearmament but I don't think
that's correct I think for most
realignments more alignment it's gonna
have to do with converting one Christian
sect to another I guarantee you
okay now was the thinking of the time
can you it's just funny if you call the
cult that nowadays it's like a bit like
yeah no thank you
yeah like what well [ __ ] like that back
in the day would have been considered to
be cool yeah you can get away with it by
just hauling [ __ ] what it was yeah and
like give you these completely ironic
names no yeah exactly
we're gonna realign your morals
Protestantism yeah get you away from
that evil Catholicism yeah too loyal to
the Pope
so that was yes so that was how that was
like part of the history this place that
place later that cult like later went
off to Switzerland and died out
presumably they the old yeah doesn't
even last 20 years it's either that or
they all get on the [ __ ] hale-bopp
comet Yankees with their quarters we
gotta do a show about that eventually I
did show my Bachelorette I remember when
that happened that blew my [ __ ] mind
I had a hard time accepting that that
the hale-bopp comet cult was real dad
dude got his own dick off yeah that's
some that's some faint there other ways
we're doing other words were doing it no
you couldn't pay me quit moving around
you're making the camera Blair look what
you did wait am I gonna blur yeah okay
so he starts moving more cameras had too
much to drink you're projecting
alright so the cult [ __ ] off to
Switzerland much like the Native
Americans that [ __ ] out from the
island you know beginning and then for a
little while it was a college Mackinac
College now in 1970 another evangelist
cuz you know there's no shortage of
those purchased the land again and was
trying to like make it into a religious
retreat but that didn't really work out
two years later they actually it was
bought out by another company who made
it into a vacation resort which is still
is to this day and like I said it's a
very popular tourist destination is a
very popular tourist destination the
whole island so this mission Point
Resort is like composed of several
different buildings and it's like you
know it's a big piece of land now the
most a haunted place in this particular
resort is supposed to be the Island
House Hotel now the most famous story
about this hotel is that when this place
was a college um there was a student
there who's usually given the name of
Harvey um he actually asked his
girlfriend to marry him and she said no
evidently like in front of all their
friends and it was like super
embarrassing so he committed suicide
now the story was he either jumped off
the bluff or he shot himself in the head
but he is supposedly sent to still haunt
the area now there have been some later
reports that he was maybe murdered
because there were like some rumors
going around they found his body in the
barrel actually two shots in his head
like one in the back of the head like so
he couldn't have done that and blah blah
blah now one thing I should note and
this is one thing I did remember from
the ghost hunters episode was that the
girl on there I can't report her name is
but she said oh I actually found the the
case that corresponds to this crime but
I'm not gonna tell you the guys name
because blah blah blah blah and I was
just kind of like really silly
I tried to find it and I couldn't find
anything I have a feeling that this is
all legend
so made-up story I mean did a guy really
kill himself you know it's possible
obviously but what what is the statistic
likelihood that on an island that's four
square miles something like this would
happen I would think I'm likely for the
population of one like four or five
hundred you can't say that that would
because it just sounds to convene if
it's just one guy but it bothers me that
every single story about it it just just
gives his first name yeah no one knows
his last name no one knows the exact
what was the year more or less it was
supposedly in the 60s and there would be
[ __ ] rock-solid documentation that's
what I thought like that's why I started
digging for like old newspaper reports
and I didn't find anything
no 67p I'm not calling the ghost hunters
Liars I'm just saying that I didn't find
anything in in a very luck on your bars
I'm just gonna call it [ __ ] I just
looked really quick and I did well just
based on what you're telling me you know
yeah I haven't done the research myself
it's just now so if there was a homicide
there or a suicide by the in the 1960s
it would be documented you know I mean
it just would well yeah it would be in
the criminal record that's what I
thought yeah that's why I went looking
for it I like I said I just did it very
like I didn't do like an in-depth
investigation or anything but I looked
quick like I googled it and I couldn't
find it in the books that you write you
can get documentation going back to the
20s that [ __ ] that actually happened
it's documented and people know about it
yeah like for instance you know this
yeah when a murder happens in US and
it's in the newspaper and there was
actually a conviction and everything you
can actually find the paper trail now
well yeah like you know there was a
ripper ya know there was a ripper well
like I said that's the thing that
bothers me is that even though the
stories usually say that this Harvey
person committed suicide you know
yeah there were like rumors later that
maybe he was murdered blah blah blah but
it's like I don't I don't know I don't
really know how true that is but that's
what well like one of the stories that
goes around that was the extent of your
bill and Harvey is supposedly one of the
ghosts that haunts the mission Point
Resort now supposedly he's not a real
he's more playful ghost than malevolent
like he usually like just as practical
joke II type [ __ ] like you're sleeping
in your room he's like hi I'm turn all
the lights on like you just poltergeist
up [ __ ] like that I'm good
evidently like you know any of
rearranges your furniture why not now
Mission Point Resort or the island house
hotel which is part of the mission war
resort also has one particular room
where the bed is bolted to the wall and
bolted to the floor so they're kind of
wondering if that has something to do
with like some spirit activity just
because it kept shakin so they figured
they'd better weld it to the wall who
did this
well the hotel did it the hotel did it
so I guess a lot of people know a lot of
people complained look okay could it
have been part of the mythos of the
hotel see this is another thing that
bothers me this is another thing that
bothers me is because okay man it's both
issues well and particularly now because
you know you have travel channel you
have destination America you have those
channels that do like you know ghost
tour type yeah [ __ ] or like here's this
haunted in this is that in the other and
I feel like if you're a hotel it
behooves you to be haunted to say that
you have a ghost particularly one room
that's haunted because then you're gonna
get everybody one in the [ __ ] world
one that they'll pay more maybe yeah and
like do some creepy [ __ ] like I would do
that if I owned a hotel like I don't you
would do that you would fake it sure
okay yeah yeah okay well if it yeah if
it was a hotel and they'd be like you
know you gonna like have a story about
it's like oh I'm just gonna I'm gonna
bolt that [ __ ] to the wall then
everybody'll wonder why it's bolted to
the bomb I'm not gonna say why it's
bolted to the wall I'm just gonna like
AK Thomas
[ __ ] I wouldn't do it you wouldn't do it
no I would do it see there it's not you
I'm just I abandoned some creepy [ __ ]
I'm not gonna make [ __ ] up but if other
people make [ __ ] up
I'll capitalize ok so you've seen you
that wouldn't invent the haunting no no
no if there was a haunting story there
you'd axle all right and I'm just saying
that other hotels were doing that as
well so buyer beware right so like I
said I don't know I don't know if this
Harvey person was real I don't know um
so the mission Point Resort also has
another ghost who was a little girl and
they call her Lucy I don't know that sir
really her name or not now apparently
she died on the island of an illness
like while her parents were away and she
kind of like died before they could come
back and be with her whatever now this
little girl has been seen all around the
resort she's in the auditorium she's
seen in the theater on the balcony of
the hotel um and also she's like her
voice sometimes gets heard like she's
calling for her mom and things like that
around the resort also other people have
said they've seen apparitions of
soldiers like walking around this resort
too so you know like I said the faceless
villain a collection of the eeriest
unsolved murders of the 20th century
volume 2 includes cases spanning the
years from 1960 through 1979 featuring
such infamous crimes as the triple
homicide at Lake Bodom the family
massacre known as the good heart murders
the serial killings of the Zodiac Bible
John Jack the stripper and the freeway
phantom the slaughter of dozens of women
and girls along the highway of tears and
the Texas killing fields and the
mysterious death of suspected spy the is
doll woman along with dozens of other
fascinating and horrifying accounts by
it now from Amazon in print Kindle or
audiobook format
yeah
tear that bunny off that's right yeah
are you gonna love the bunny today you
can love the bunny it's like no kill the
bunny bunny and almost as big as you are
it's almost as big as you are
look you got a bunny and you got treats
this is a good day she's like I don't
know I'm conflicted right no treats okay
everybody ginnis guys a new shirt
designs up four of them really good ones
to Atlanta Ripper who put Bella in the
witch out the HH Holmes murder castle
and of course demon child cuz man said
he could these are updated designs I
think they look really cool Jenny did a
great job
bottom were they fun making Jenny they
were very fun and thank you very much I
think they came out ready yeah a really
good they're very high-quality shirts
Jenny and I we're sure our own shirts at
certain times when we're trying to put
spotlight on ourselves and you can put a
spotlight on yourselves if you go ahead
and pick up on these shirts today you
guys are gonna love them
mix in the description WWL comm at 13
o'clock yes ago check out our store at
wwl calm / 13 o'clock we got these four
cool new t-shirt designs plus all our
old ones if you'd rather get one of the
old ones but these ones are awesome and
you should check them out they're also
available in women's cotton they look
really cute JD's got some so thank you
go check them out
okay we're back from the break again
again all right so one of the other
haunted places on Mackinac Island is
known as the Grand Hotel now the story
about this one is that when they were
building this the builders came across
so many skeletons presumably Native
American skeletons then after a while
they just said [ __ ] it and just started
building anyway because they couldn't
you know I mean they were coming crusted
only they were in the middle of a
cemetery yeah so they were just kind of
like whatever they're just like you know
what I mean
so it's just kind of like poltergeist
like you only move the hats no there's
no like that kind of situation where
they just like couldn't deal with it
anymore so they just said what were they
building again a hotel Oh death Grand
Hotel it's like I said it's still there
so they don't know if these were
actually Native American skeletons or if
these were bodies that much like
poltergeist were left behind when the
old post cemetery was moved and they
just left the bodies there so like I
said the story goes that all these
bodies were left there but they just
built the hotel over it so that's
supposedly super haunted also there's
also another hotel called the Marie
hotel now in this hotel reportedly a
woman was sexually assaulted and
murdered in her room in her hotel room
and that she is haunting the place to
because her murder was never solved to a
date on that no like I said this is all
like these are Lakeland and I'm not
saying that didn't happen I'm just
saying that it's kind of hard to track
down the actual crimes that their local
legends
right right so there's another place to
call the in it stone cliff and this is
apparently a very popular wedding
destination for couples wanted to get
married because it is very scenic I've
seen pictures of it um so apparently
this place is haunted by a woman who's
she had a fiance he
was British and but he died before they
could get married and she got really
pissed off about it so after she died
she decided she was gonna hang around
this Inn and [ __ ] up everyone's weddings
like from now until forever because she
was really because she's like a
vindictive [ __ ] like that so that's how
that story I get that girl so in the
same vein there's another place like I
said there's so many like little Inns
and cottages and stuff on here there's
one called small point cottage also now
this was originally built in 1882 it
started out as a private residence but
in 1971 it was bought by a teacher named
John Finley he moved to Mackinac Island
because he was gonna teach at the
elementary school there so he bought it
to live there
now he said that as soon as he and his
family moved into this cottage that they
were subjected to violent poltergeist
activity they had all kind of like weird
unexplained sounds voices things going
missing furniture moving around so all
this kind of [ __ ] now supposedly even
though like I said you know how we feel
about poltergeist person you know so
it's two different things
yeah they throat they throw this [ __ ]
concept of poltergeist activity throw it
around like [ __ ] crazy
yeah with no regard to what pair of
psychologists from the 50s and the 60s
and the 70s from what they say
poltergeist is and and actually based on
my personal experience I agree with what
the pair of psychologists of the 60s
said that it's our spk
yeah from from a kid going through
puberty who's in a certain environment
okay now so we'll say that maybe a ghost
can produce poltergeist like effects
yeah but that's not the same as a
poltergeist outbreak it's complicated
well I bet you look at our poltergeist
shows yeah I kind of do agree there's
probably like two different things like
most I don't know most like paranormal
tape
that you see nowadays yeah do you make
the distinction between ghosts and
poltergeists like you see them as
although like worry where there's yeah a
ghost can make poltergeist you know but
a ghost is a poltergeist I don't believe
it is now I saw a poltergeist I didn't
believe it was a ghost I thought it was
a ghost at the time but looking back on
it because that was you know 13 we came
back on it no our is PK yeah yeah well
and like I said this particular thing
that happened in the early 70s I mean it
seemed like poltergeist activity but the
story goes that it was caused by you
know the ghost of a little girl that had
lived there and died there or whatever
the place is a bed-and-breakfast now and
evidently there's still some activity
going on there and apparently it's not
to the extent of it's not like nothing
on the on here seems particularly
violent or scary it does seem like
tourists will go there particularly to
you know see these particular like
they'll go stay in these places to see
this particular activity so it seems
like it's more playful or more you know
what I mean like not threatening or
anything like that except for one
location on gets a little bit later in
my opinion I've seen poltergeist all
right yes Geist is what they said in the
1960s it's ours PK but I also went into
a house that I thought was haunted and
it was very different all right
based on what I saw I don't think a
ghost can move anything I think maybe
it's mostly just gonna be feelings
feelings of being watched you know maybe
you might have some bad dreams there or
maybe some visions you might see an
apparition I didn't see an apparition I
do have bad dreams there yeah but maybe
in a very haunted place you might
actually see an apparition I don't know
if a ghost can move a physical object
I'm just you know I've never seen it
myself
I saw poche guys do it but I don't think
a poltergeist was a go
like I said I think the current
spontaneous psychokinesis
subconsciousness yeah I think it's two
very different things but I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna say that it's impossible
maybe well you guys can move an object
this is kind of the thing where no one's
an expert oh yeah there's no real book
on this they're just stories yeah you
know everything has to do with what you
see and the experience that you're
having you know there are some people
that have been in what they say is a
haunted place and that that goes to move
to an object I'm not gonna call him a
liar yeah yeah and this is just some
ridiculous [ __ ] you go man you look from
my personal experience which was a
poltergeist experience also like an
out-of-body experience Mountain
poltergeist you guys to see it from my
experience stuff like this usually isn't
real dramatic you know I mean in terms
of like you know a lot of a movie
poltergeist form of flashing lights and
[ __ ] it's not really like that
I don't know can a ghost move an object
maybe are there ghosts I think there
might be yeah I'm not sure they can move
it out I don't think there I think there
might be good although something that's
interesting and that just reminded me of
that you know that movie Ghost with
Patrick Swayze and to me more in it yeah
that has like a whole sequence where
Patrick Swayze has to learn how to move
physical objects yeah from another ghost
because he can't do it well look if you
of a living person ghost
astral and has an out-of-body experience
which I've had that I do believe you can
move an object I do can they're worse
there was kind of like an RS PK outburst
when I when I went out all right but
can't a ghost do it you know can't a
dead person do this I kind of think no
yeah based on what I saw you die and you
go into the afterworld
you go into a higher plane and you lose
touch with the material world but let's
just say you could you know maybe that
was just my experience from based on
what I felt having a near-death
experience and an out-of-body experience
let's say somebody's died since he's
focused in the material world and tries
to move things yeah that's hard to say
maybe they could maybe they could you
know I guess we've seen yes there's no
way of knowing maybe they could but for
how long how long would you hang out how
long would you hang around as a dead
person how long could you be fixated
yeah I mean on something material the
material aspect of your mortal life you
know I mean what are you gonna worry
about losing a woman for a hundred years
you know what's the deal I'm not sure
now there's a theory about residual
haunting okay where the where the ghost
is not really there it's just like the
behavior of the ghost where it has
remained like it's it's in a dream state
like an echo from the past maybe that I
would think that maybe that is more
likely that makes more sense it makes
more sense to me because honestly if you
were dead why the [ __ ] would you hang
around yeah I don't think you hang
around because watch anything you can't
eat anything I had a motorcycle accident
in case you guys are new listeners had a
motorcycle accident when I was an army
that was documented okay I was in a coma
for about a week alright and I had the
near-death experience with a life review
and and then talking to a I guess a god
or a dame on you know I'm in and I just
I just have a feeling that when you die
when you really die you don't have any
interest in your past life anymore cuz
you're not you're very different
after you've shed this mortal coil you
know I mean you're not really I was not
really fixated on who I was as Tom Ross
that was just like a character from the
past like when you're playing a video
game
game character the year playing dies he
just started a new game you don't really
care about that last one and that was
kind of like yeah it was like you know I
also had an out-of-body experience
before no but like I'm says well no
that's kind of an interesting thing to
think about because this is something
like we should do because I mean people
are interested in this like if you die
before me or if I die before you like if
I could come back and tell you some [ __ ]
I would you probably wouldn't be
interested you'd be like oh well no he's
gonna be okay
I got [ __ ] I got a do-over here in the
net and the next violation I would feel
bad like I said what I thought was a
violation of the natural order that
there's a natural order and you've
agreed to it already
now when you have an OBE which is like
astral projection it's very different
because you're not dead your
consciousness has left your body and
it's in a world of like extrasensory
world you know in even the army believed
in this with Project Star Gate where
they were doing remote viewing which was
a slightly different version of astral
projection they didn't like astral
projection they wanted to do remote
viewing which i think is a cheap version
of astral projection but and for me
astral projection was an accident it
only happened a couple times it was
spontaneous you know I do you feel like
if this [ __ ] happens it happens when you
don't mean it to like you're not trying
to you're in a certain part of your life
you know I mean it's you're in a very
peaceful moment when it happens and then
you just kind of slip out yeah you know
and it happened to me when I was younger
I think as you get older you're probably
you might be less likely to do it
because you just don't really have the
curiosity or you can't take Drive and
you just don't give a [ __ ] enough yeah
because death comes anyway that's great
you can tanker ascend you're - I feel
like your your psyche and your body
become more like intertwined like you
get older and become more solid more
more founded in realism maybe that's a
you're not as you know but you
in order to ask for a project you have
to have kind of a mentality of [ __ ] I
guess you could say it's the ultimate
form of liberation you're giving up the
ghost literally you have any fear of
death or anything you know yeah but then
you're which is kind of like in the
movie frighteners yeah I mean that's one
of the reason why I like that movie
frighteners yeah I gotta have an Alex by
experience right now there's a lot of
lot of the stuff that I saw kind of
lined up in the movie Fridays that's why
you like that movie like that's some
really good yeah well you know they're
kind of approach it was playful from a
playful yeah a few point but yeah kind
of like you saw frighteners yeah I ever
said there's another fear of death we're
all gonna die but it's not the end
don't worry about it I'm not worried so
much about dying I just don't want like
bad [ __ ] to happen before that you don't
I mean yeah the suffering yeah that's
what I mean like death doesn't seem
super scary it's just like falling
asleep but like I've suffered a lot in
the Army you know I don't want like bad
[ __ ] happening before that I suffered a
lot in the infantry you know I'm at 5:06
I know up in Korea you know intense cold
intense you know sleep deprivation you
you you're definitely seeing phantom
mcdonough
seeing phantom McDonald's you know you
bring in you forget about it very
quickly it passes it's kind of like
every woman I know that has had a baby
yeah the time I've said the same thing
it's like it really sucked at the time
like it really hurt they forget
yeah that's Nature's Way of saying hey
have another one yeah great didn't hurt
that bad it wasn't yeah it comes like
that yeah that's kind of what it's like
they make you forget about that Jen so
yeah all right let's get back to Mack an
island all right so there's some like
other haunted [ __ ] in here - there's
like another place that's called small
point College it's cottage now this was
originally built in 1882
I started out as a private residence but
there was actually
this guy bought it in the 60s called Bob
Huey and he lived in it and he also like
ran it as a restaurant called little
Bob's now him and his wife lived there
and they started having all this like
weird like ghostly tech phenomena
happening there they kept hearing like
disembodied footsteps doors opening
closing stuff like that you know [ __ ]
like that like we've seen around here in
this house now he also claimed to have
seen an apparition that was a woman that
he only he said he only saw her like
from the waist up like she didn't have
any legs and like she would like swish
through the house now like you were just
saying about ghosts not being able to
touch people and stuff like that he said
that she like would swish through and
like knocked him aside yeah well I
wanted to say that ghosts can't touch it
ghosts might be able to touch it but I
was saying is that a ghost that I'm not
sure it goes can move something yeah
maybe they can your average goes to
probably can't yeah now when you say it
goes touch me that's weird
because it it might be that you sense
the ghost yeah so therefore you thought
that ghost touched you but you know what
I mean yeah if there was a ghost it
would be kind of like a quantum energy
field of consciousness you know I mean a
being there there wouldn't be a body
yeah so you would might perceive it as
it touched you but you know I would
think well I know yeah this I just saw
certain things that I saw this guy said
he saw an apparition that looked like
the upper half of a woman no legs
she came out of a closet and like swish
passed him like out of a closet in like
toward a window and like kind of knocked
him over in the process and that he saw
that on more than one occasion right so
that's what he said and then later on he
says a bunch of other [ __ ] - it's like
they would hear like phantom crying it
sounds like a little girl
they also later said that they saw like
like sort of shadow figures
like ghosts are like men like standing
by their beds and stuff like that like
in the middle of the night um they
eventually moved out of the house
because they couldn't take it anymore so
I guess it's like a bed-and-breakfast
now like a lot of these places are on
the island because like I said some big
tourist destination and some tourists
have reported similar type of activity
like seeing like shadow figures like
standing by their beds when they wake up
in the middle of night you see these
businesses these businesses are involved
it always makes me kind of skeptical
because they all have a vested interest
you know because that's like that's like
a big selling point yeah like if you
have a bed-and-breakfast or if you have
a hotel you gotta have a haunted room
come on everybody loves that [ __ ] you
might be able to you might have ohed you
know okay look let's be real about this
[ __ ] chances are it's a small little
island as creepy maybe there was a
couple little occurrences that happened
there you know what I mean it might
that's probably the truth of it you know
I mean yeah we'll see I mean I'm just
saying not everything can be on it no I
know you know Tama well you know it's a
rare phenomenon yeah so okay let's see
what else oh there's also another place
there's it's called
the mission house now early settlers to
this island they built this particular
house it was a Christian mission they
were of course trying to convert those
heathen natives to Christianity like
they were all trying to do at the time
now evidently at one point an epidemic
of tuberculosis hit this particular
mission now the Native children that
were at this place
they thought oh well the best way to
cure them is we're gonna put them down
in the basement because there's really
nice cold damp air down there and that's
going to cure their tuberculosis so they
locked him all down in the basement and
reportedly some of them died down there
and some of the kids were evidently not
happy about it and still like haunt the
place now so at this point like in the
present day like some people have said
they seem like kids running around or
heard like kids giggling or whatever now
one of the places in like I said most of
the hauntings on the island are
supposedly like from everything that
everybody that stayed there so they're
pretty innocuous like it's usually like
playful type stuff like people just like
hey I'm just gonna move your [ __ ] or
it's just like kids laughing or
something like that
one of the more sinister places on the
island said it'd be a place called the
drowning pool now this place in the
1700's and 1800's reportedly there were
seven women who lived on the island who
were essentially prostitutes now for
whatever reason these particular
prostitutes were later suspected of
witchcraft and as they used to do back
in the day they said hey since you're
suspected of witchcraft let's tie some
rocks to your ankles and throw you in a
lake and see if you float or if you sink
and that will determine your innocence
or your guilt this this is not checking
out with me it's just not little island
like that back in those days would most
likely have prostitutes people had
prostitutes you know well there was
there was the world's oldest yeah we'll
see that's why I said why these
particular seven processes they just
like piss one person off yeah that's
kind of what I'm thinking
these girls were like prostitution Malfi
or maybe common during that era and just
because they were prostate doesn't mean
they were which has been a probably
probably most likely they would be the
last ones to be accused of witches cuz
they was to be guild
well yeah it's like why would you think
that like do we like no those are the
price not those no those aren't which
those girl kills that yeah you need
those yeah we need those that's that's
it
yeah well that's what I mean like if
this actually happened I feel like maybe
these women
we're doing some other [ __ ] I don't
think that has that the dudes it didn't
like I'm just saying so far from what
you're telling me a lot of this stuff I
just don't think it happened well like a
lot of this has the stink of legend it
has the stink of legend then it has the
stink of a small island with a bunch of
hotels on it trying to attract customers
yes ma'am although like I said they
don't really seem to be having trouble
in that area because they really do have
a like a lot of and like I said I've
seen some pictures of it and if any of
you guys have been there like tell me
about it because it looks super cool
like for the pictures it looks a lot
like you know I'm from Florida so we
have st. Augustine you know the oldest
permanent settlement in the United
States and it looks kind of like that
where you get you like your horse-drawn
carriages like you get your really
old-school looking houses yet like your
old chair for like the 1500s and
everything like that um so it looks like
that and it looks super cool so if
you've been there like on vacation let
me know have you seen any ghosts or
anything like that but apparently this
place the drowning pool so apparently
these seven women were thrown into this
area and I have a picture of it it's
just like this kind of you know little
pool essentially where they supposedly
through them and drown them and you know
I was reading this one thing about it
said hey good news they're not witches
bad news they try out you know a because
they threw him in there with the rocks
and everything there's a lot of
misconceptions about that because when
they were actually drowning witches if
they started to drown they pulled him
out it was the ones that floated that
were the witches yeah because yeah the
water was rejecting yeah water but like
I said if they threw you in there and
they're like hey she sunk and then they
didn't get you out in time yeah you
would total but they pulled him out did
they yeah yeah I looked into that they
didn't they betterments around they
didn't let him drown it they just
started to drown they went other
drowning that means they're not witches
pull him out they had him on ropes yeah
they did pull him out yeah they didn't
kill him I hope they did yeah because
otherwise that'd be pretty nice stuff so
if you're being accused of being a witch
and they're doing the water was in your
interest to [ __ ] his ground yeah because
if you start a flow they would say well
she's away every sin I'm just gonna run
down to the bike
like people would know that like you
think women would be smart enough to be
like hey don't flow just like it was
another time who knows how swim down to
the bottom who knows how smart they were
I'm not sure not sure they were all that
smart
well like you know I don't like this
[ __ ] on People magazine you know they're
probably just well mostly a smart smart
could they be there well maybe sure
there are witches yeah but I'm sure
they're as smart as average people
nowadays who are not that smart but they
were accusing each other of witches and
accusing each other of being witches in
a way to where you couldn't prove your
innocence yeah so there wasn't a lot of
logic involved with what they did I
don't think there was I think that was
on purpose though because I think they
wanted that as like a fallback for like
hey we don't like this person so we're
just gonna but the crowd wouldn't call
[ __ ] on it that was the weird like
why would you a lot of people wouldn't
do it nowadays people are not smarter
now I read it cuz I read a couple of
occasions where they were accused a
young girl of being a witch and people
did come forward and call [ __ ] on it
there was one where there was a military
officer came forward soon and that was
about the little ghost needle parts
where they were taking needles hold on
put that same needle in this area on
this woman and see if it raised you yes
well like I said not everyone was done
that well and honestly I think a lot
less people were dumbasses and people
think because if you came forward and
said hey that's all [ __ ] then they'd
probably accuse you of witchcraft and
you would get your ass well the officer
that did that only did it once he didn't
come back and try to save anybody else
so other people might have been thinking
it but we're like well I better not say
anything cuz otherwise my ass will be in
a sling well that [ __ ] was a moral panic
it was just like right satanic panic and
panic so you have today so like I said I
don't think everyone was a dummy I'm
sure most people were like this is
[ __ ] but they don't want to say
anything because then their ass would be
grass too I'm just saying but yeah so
the drowning pool the story goes that
seven women who were supposedly I love
had like different places we were like
promiscuous they were prostitutes
evidently and so they get accused
oh crap they got throwing the thing they
drown blah blah blah so now this place
is supposedly said to be haunted too
many people have reported seeing like
kind of just weird like shadows like
right into the water or like big huge
splashes when there are no fishes
they're just you know creepy [ __ ] like
that most people that have visited this
area of reported feeling like a a really
creepy like dread type of feeling like
this is like I said most of the other
hauntings on the island seemed pretty
benevolent the drowning pool seems like
it's a more malevolent type of haunting
like most people that go there say they
don't really feel good about being there
like it's not really a kind of a nice
place to be I'm buying it you never do
prostitution was not that much of a
stigma back then you know there's a
common it was a common profession yeah
yeah I mean we didn't want to marry a
prostitute but you know many guys we
could definitely work Oh cuz oh and
[ __ ] but they definitely were gonna
kill him who's gonna why would you want
to introduct the whole supply you had to
there were men out there that were not
there was the holy supply there were
there were men out there that were not
marriage material you know what I mean
that depended on that that was their
only you know there's only actually
everyone get do not cut into the whole
supply yeah well back in the days there
were just as the shortage of women in in
a new world there was enough women
there's a weddin no just telling you
when enough of you had to share we're a
prized commodity has affairs and you'll
remember there was like to pay for it
that's the way they were this way it was
back then
[Laughter]
alright well documented you know no I
know
actually uh one thing I remember and I
can't remember the name of the book but
it was like a really fascinating book
about
kind of high-class prostitutes yeah in
England like at the time we like the
ones that brand the brothels and stuff
and that [ __ ] is [ __ ] fascinating
yeah one thing I found United States to
their what yeah Akhter ins I read about
ones in Chicago yeah it was like a whole
there was a whole bunch of them and like
Chicago that ran a bunch of brothels and
stuff well the thing about prostitutes
that I found interesting from back in
the day was that prostitutes if you ran
a brothel if you are a madam you
actually had a lot more pop attitude and
power than an average woman at the time
he's like even someone that was married
to someone was a lot of money and stuff
like that they were how you died the
boundaries right you didn't have like a
lot of the same strictures that other
like quote-unquote society women had at
the time so in a way you kind of had an
advantage and also they were celebrities
yeah a high value prostitute actually
was where the term star came from yeah
because in the United States a very
wealthy and successful process who
didn't want to be known just for that so
they had theaters and they would had
they would they could sing and they can
they could put on a show so that's what
they would do they put on a show every
night and they would have their name
inside of a star named with the stars
and then afterwards they turn their
tricks and yeah this everybody knows
about this that's where this that's
where the word star came from and it's
similar kind of [ __ ] that goes on now
he's like he said yeah yeah so dudes
didn't want to be just prostitutes they
wanted to be actresses and singers and
you know well you know they were trying
to like yeah branch out
yeah and deal with it you know well you
know awake until a woman doesn't want to
be known just for that all along and
known just for that they want they had
other things to offer right it's sing
and they could put on shows and they
were entertainers that would also
increase the value of the services yeah
that day that they get they oh that's
what I mean that's why I always like
kind of respected like a lot of the sex
workers back in the day not only because
they were outside of the strictures
a lot of the you know social [ __ ]
boundaries that were kind of fencing in
women back at the time Torian era yeah
you could like kind of get away with a
lot more they were scenesters yeah but
they you know they were kind of like the
entrepreneurs of their day it's like
they kind of understood the value of
like vertical marketing and they were
just like you know they were getting out
there and doing that and a star back in
those days they weren't messing around
the rabble they were dealing with rich
guys this is like a tail in a way this
was kind of like old-school dating
because they didn't date back then and
didn't yeah it's a very recent it's
funny how they're like you taking a [ __ ]
right about dating but it's like a
recent development back in the old day
you kind of like got set up you know
what I mean it's like what was what's
the most true reaction marriages or yeah
get married that's the most strategic
really well how and if you are how you
were still you could be a star and
really I think probably the average
woman of today if they were to try if
you were to transport them into the past
with a time in it like a time machine
they probably don't want to be a married
woman of that era you'd probably want to
be a star I definitely would that would
be more closely to I wouldn't have no
with night you would have the rights and
the abilities you are right that you are
more used to having yeah they were free
yeah I would be stuck in some don't Taos
he's like no you can't have a job you
can't have a bank account you can't have
any rights you can't vote you can't do
anything you girls all live like hose
the hose of the past free women was a
house well that's what I mean I mean and
that's why I found like that kind of
[ __ ] fasting like reading about a lot of
these like you know brothel owners and
stuff like in Chicago in England and
stuff like that yeah these women were
like way ahead of their time like they
were very progressive for the time like
they have their [ __ ] together man they
know what they were doing that's why
when I hear these legends of oh well
they're prostitutes so we're gonna drown
them in the well no that's not the way
it was we drowned
prostitute those were the most popular
most powerful women in the [ __ ]
society back in those days yeah they
were the free women in the New Orleans
it was all about octoroon balls and quad
room balls they had white women
pertained to be octoroon
because an octoroon was worth more than
a white woman really you know they were
the geisha of the south back in that era
yeah so you can't take all this [ __ ] for
face value by today's standards and
listen to these you know you can't be
the world was different back then you
have to [ __ ] do your research and go
back in the past and see how these
people were perceived in their day yeah
okay in their day these women were that
you know doctor wounds and prostitutes
now not all of them star prostitutes
word well a birdís they had their own
money they had their own huge apartments
right they did like parties they could
like a low-level Street prostitute or a
hag no you were [ __ ] well same as now
same as now street prostitutes are still
drugged that's that's something you fall
into if you that's all you if you're
desperate like you don't have anything
else to do you know what I mean but like
these women actually like kind of
someone who were forced into a bit late
they kind of like made the choice well
I'm just gonna do this [ __ ] and then
like they yeah a lot of them had to do
that but they said whoa okay well I'm
gonna they spun it around into power
Yeah right
which like I said the best right I
respect that it's what they do and
that's why that [ __ ] so fascinating to
me right you can't use modern terms yeah
all right so no I mean we've talked a
little bit about Mac and Iowa like I
said somebody requested this every place
on this [ __ ] is hot it's haunted it
looks suspicious well yes I would like
to go there because it looks super cool
yeah I'm just saying the paranormal
aspect of what's suspicious to me I
think I'm looking at I'm thinking of a
bubble it'd be a creepy ass island yeah
you know it does look great
I like to see that architecture on it
and like I said no motorized vehicles
other than emergency vehicles other than
snowmobiles but it's mostly horse Shawn
I where I'd like to see that he would
the ghost aspect isn't really calling to
me okay yeah I would just rather see the
island itself well it would be like some
good seclusion when you think about it
it's the same thing it's the same way I
feel about like I said I'm from Florida
so it's the same way I feel about st.
Augustine it's that like a lot of people
are like oh this is haunted that's
haunted like everything's haunted in st.
Augustine which it is you know so they
say but I actually like going there just
because I like looking at the
architecture he wants to do a show from
saying all I do but we might do that
eventually she wants to get where we're
walking around and showing you this
stuff I'm not sure you know how much
because it's not that far from here it's
only I mean I only grew up about 15
miles from st. Augustine I used to go
there every year
several times a year when I was I
wouldn't mind doing it I just don't know
how much people would be interested I
mean yeah well like I said it's the
oldest permanent settlement in the
United States like there's super there's
this huge Spanish fort there that's
beautiful yeah
oldest jail all the schoolhouse there's
an alligator farm
I love the alligator farm no the
alligator farm is really rad you guys
it's like it's like a big zoo I mean
they call it alligator farm but it's
like it's actually a really big zero
they have money you guys want to see
that just hit us up in the comments
we're thinking about doing it for the
hundred and fiftieth yeah but we're
still arguing about whether we stood
[ __ ] weighing it out I'm not sure
whether or not it's worth it you know
maybe I've been there a bunch of times
and I really like it and I think it's
like it's it's a cool area like I
wouldn't do anything like cheesy-ass
ghost or anything but it's just a cool
place to like walk around there's like a
lot of really cool like old cemeteries
and [ __ ] like that and I think it would
be like you think we can turn that into
it cool to do like an on location show
like just for a special event like 150th
episode 200th episode something like
that so I'm kind of thinking about doing
that but he's not sure
he's not convinced I'm not convincing
because he's never been there he's never
there so he doesn't have to see some
pictures of it yeah so like I said
Mackinac Island I wasn't sure if like
this topic would take up the whole show
or not did so well it kind of did
because we're already at what like an
hour and 40 minutes or something it took
it up but I you know I was gonna like
put in some other [ __ ] about because
there are a lot of like other kind of
ghost stories about like other [ __ ]
about the grace the Great Lakes like
there's a lot of like ghosts so yeah
more yeah there's like a lot of like
ghost ship type stories you got your
South Bay Bessie which is kind of like a
Loch Ness Modi government a Fatima type
situation
well let's kind of talk about like go
ships ghost ships because here's the
thing about the Great Lakes what a lot
of people like maybe if you're not from
the United States you don't know but the
Great Lakes there actually sees the sign
yeah they're kind of like English water
oceans yeah like yeah they're you know
technically yeah they're Lakes but the
conditions on them are much more akin to
ocean conditions yeah I mean they're
vinegars there have been [ __ ] cargo
ships capsized in a lot yes so there's
about the cargo ship record that's all
that happened in the Great Lakes that's
yeah that's so like I said there's it's
not like a kind of thing where it was
just a like Bloods they have all that
kind of [ __ ] going on it's like all
ocean kind of [ __ ] our lakes are bigger
than your European countries that's how
badass United States is technically yeah
well I'm gonna say specifically the
Great Lakes take up a total area of
almost ninety five thousand square miles
what y'all gonna do about that those are
big [ __ ] Lake like I said they have
like ocean conditions yeah now as big as
these lakes are they even have a thing
called the Lake Michigan triangle it's
like the Bermuda Triangle but it's like
Lake Michigan where like ships
and planes that [ __ ] like disappear in
there there's also been mysterious fish
sighted in these like big fish also
moment also Merman big fish yeah
there's Lake Michigan mermen like I said
there's like a Nessie type situation
going on there South Bay Bessie's are
stories of like gigantic [ __ ] grouper
and stuff like that you know what it's
like every time somebody says something
about like [ __ ] giant grouper yeah I
believe that [ __ ] because I've seen
grouper yeah they're big yeah a grouper
bigger than a shark they're big and even
like ones that I've seen like in [ __ ]
aquariums are just like when I was out
fishing or whatever like that they're
like scary large they could fit man they
could fit your entire head in their
mouth very easily yeah also they're
delicious so feed a family of 12 well no
like if you're a bird like this I give
the cows like catching a cow it is
they're as big as a cow
well like bigger than a cow but um if
you're ever I'm not sure if it's still
there but I grew up in Daytona Beach but
there was a place that's right over
wanted like the main bridge there like
from the beach and there was a place
that they used to have like the best
[ __ ] group or sandwiches what the
[ __ ] was the name of that place I can't
remember it right now but they had
really really good and they they had
their own boat said they would like go
out in the Atlantic Ocean cuz it was
like right there yeah I can explain what
a grouper is a grouper might be like a
cod right I don't know it looks like
they have like a big giant tuna but it's
a freshwater tuna big lips like a
gigantic they look like bass Connie but
they're really really big and really
make that like big
yeah like I remember like going to Sea
World when I was a kid and I've always
been scared of sharks my whole life even
though I grew up like right on the ocean
but every time like sharks like freaked
me out ever since I saw jaws and stuff
like that but I went to SeaWorld and
they have that big thing where you can
go through the the path and like it's in
the middle of the big
where iam and you just go through the
middle of it when and it's like all the
with the windows like all around and
you're like [ __ ] see and there's like
all these sharks water and [ __ ] that was
scary
the grouper scared me worse because they
were bigger the groupers were bigger
than the sharks yeah so and I was like
I've eaten you guys so they're gonna get
a gigantic bass ugly ass bass yeah
something that could kill you if they
wanted to
also the barracudas were very scary
because the barracudas wait a barracuda
inside the Great Lakes no no no I'm
saying it's a sweet world
yeah because they have the barracudas in
their own tank because they're [ __ ]
and they like play water fish you like
you walk through there the Barracuda
tank the barracudas will look at you
like they want to [ __ ] you up like they
see you and they will come right up to
the window and be like Walt's apprentice
[ __ ] you man [ __ ] you I see you I see
you and they do that kind of [ __ ] my dad
used to catch him off the coast
California yeah those are mean
[ __ ] I was little kid and they
used to like when I was little like I
said I grew up like right on the
Atlantic Ocean I grew up in Daytona
Beach Florida and they always used to
tell you don't wear like shiny jewelry
in the water because the barracudas will
I come and get you they'll bite you and
even in the boats they'll jump in your
boat yeah and they're not a big fish no
but they're [ __ ] they're like super
aggressive and their faces look like
supergroup they look mad they're kind of
like I don't like the kind of like the
the Jaguar of the ocean yeah like a
Jaguar of mine well they have those
teeth that are like like razor sharp and
like they will jump in your brain and
just go [ __ ] and just like slice you're
all right go ahead go on all right drunk
we're getting down so yeah like I said
well like I said the great lakes are so
large that they not only have one go
ship they have a whole fleet they have a
thing called a ghost fleet they because
their ships are lost out there yeah
because they have so many ships that
went down in the air
yeah I thought that was a creepy thing
that these ships would be lost at sea
and they're out there floating around
yeah and every now and then people see
them it's just takes me out derelict
ship it's like it's not your imagine
you're out there at night okay in a
small boat 40-foot boat 50-foot boat all
right fishing boat and a gigantic cargo
ship it's just is next to you
just moving okay now light on or
anything and it's just creepy as hell
nobody on it it's just floating around
because that's not supernatural no it's
real [ __ ] that's like a ship yeah it's
out there there's nobody on it yeah
bigger than a 20-story building yeah
quietly silently yeah with a bunch of
rats on it yeah but that man
the rats are eating each other to
survive yeah you get on there who knows
what happens to you you fall asleep the
rats come out and eat you know there's
no way of knowing man it's just creepy
should probably happen kind of reminds
me of that [ __ ] movie what was it
called about the Nazi ghost ship that
was flicking cone around whoa what was
that called the boat yeah it was like
there was a derelict ship it's a movie
about a derelict ship floating around
out in the ocean there was a Nazi death
ship I know what you're talking about
but I can't think of what yeah and some
some people in a fishing boat found it
butts to their death yeah and they got
on it and it was just bizarre man as
good there's like an early eighties
horror movie I forgot what it was called
that wasn't the keep when he was called
death ship oh yeah yeah I think that was
it was good [ __ ] because there was
actually a movie called ghost ship but I
think that was like a newer yeah wasn't
go ship the one where all those people
got cut in half by the wire at the
beginning I can't I gotta get death ship
on blu-ray
we should it's probably good that in
shockwaves yeah that was good too yeah
with we're thinking of all kind of
movies yes shockwaves had Peter Cushing
in it and he was anything with Peter
says oh I adore Christopher Lee and he's
old like a Nazi captain hanging out in
the island and off the coast the island
was a sunken submarine that had a bunch
of SS Nazis it's just Nazi [ __ ]
zombies very them can not yeah nazi
zombies that were the u-boat crew
remember they're maybe don't eat the
water goes not zombies that was the
original nazi zombie movie as far as I
know weirdly there was more than one of
those yeah yeah actually there was a lot
of those Christian kind of Christian
running around little arms skinny as a
damn skinny as a toothpick I like Peter
Cushing yeah he had a certain look I
wish I was like that pull your molars I
don't think I'd had any molars he just
had his son my molars and get all my
skin pulled back and yeah the back just
had like incisors and canines he didn't
have any molars his [ __ ] sucking he
was all yeah he was what they call the
skull people yes go people okay I like
that though we're getting sidetracked
good that's all right all right but
people that are probably listened to her
probably drunk - yeah 1970 style show
Merv Griffin we're sitting here talking
in words we're just expecting you guys
to drink - so by the time we get to the
end you won't even give a show or
talking about it anymore which is good
because that on your mobile we're
talking about no I was awesome no it's
time with the ghost bleed okay yeah go
sleep on the Great Lakes
yeah now the oldest doesn't read me out
already just you talking about
see I love ghost ship [ __ ] okay we
should do a whole other show cuz
remember we did that sea monster and
ghost ship yeah yeah my head yeah I had
super fun doing that I love that kind of
doesn't seem like anybody liked it
though but I love it I love it
for some reason why you [ __ ] scary
place yes because I mean I grew up like
right next to it so it like creeps me
out people don't understand
so the first and old
list of the ghost ships is called the
Griffon now the set sail from Lake Erie
from it was going to Lake Erie from
Niagara in August of 1679 that's how
long ago this boat was 40 tons and it
was captained by a French explorer now
apparently it was lost you know it just
vanished nobody knew what happened to it
blah blah blah now at the time because
the ship disappeared it was actually
attributed to apparently a Native
American a witch doctor and his name was
and I'm hope I'm pronouncing this right
met Co me AK and he put a curse on this
ship and he said for whatever reason
this ship was like offensive to the
Great Spirit because like I said this
island was supposedly the habitation of
the Great Spirit so the ship was
offending him for whatever reason so
this particular witch doctor put a curse
on it and so the ship disappeared and
was destined to sink so evidently it did
so this is the first of the ghost ships
from this area but there were a bunch of
other ones too there was another one
called the WH Gill chur the western
reserved this was in the late 19th
century and these were some of the
largest ships of their day you know
carrying big heavy loads of whatever but
they both also sank disappeared and they
are also said to be sometimes seen
offices sometimes you can like see them
from the shore evidently like all of
these ships can sometimes be seen from
the shore so there's another ship that's
like a member of the goose fleet it's
called the Erie Board of Trade and this
ship disappeared in 1883 on Lake Huron
now evidently the story about this one
was that the captain of the boat said
that he told one of the guys on the crew
hey climb up to the main mast you know
and it was not like in conditions that
were conducive to that so the guy crawls
up there too
whatever it was the captain said and he
fell and he died and then not long after
that the ghost of this guy was said to
like haunt the ship and the ghost was
said to have like caused the ship to
disappear because the ship did disappear
later on presumably it's sunken so that
was also one of the members of the ghost
fleet there's also a ship called the
Hudson which disappeared on September
16th 1901 on Lake Michigan now this ship
has said it like turns up people see it
always on the same date it's always on
September 16th which was the day that it
disappeared in 1901 now it was seen in
1940 by a tugboat like all the crew
members reported seeing it like they saw
like a derelict ship like with all this
like slimy [ __ ] all over it and they got
they reportedly like went on the boat
and like looked around there was nobody
on there but it was like super creepy
like no one was there so now it's
verified well like I said that was what
was reported in 1940 they said we saw
this [ __ ] ship and we got on it was
all cover slime and there's somebody on
it and supposedly that was the ship that
had disappeared in 1901
now another been there for 40 years just
floating on that creature the [ __ ] out
it's like like I said it happened it's
not even well ghosts happen before on
the ocean yeah you know like go ships
like aren't even really paranormal like
just creepy yeah it's just like a ship
that like everyone's gone off it and
it's just like kind of flute and around
yeah it imagines on and imagine where
Toby I'm talking about something that is
like the equivalent volume of a 10 or 15
story building yeah just floating around
by itself that's creepy yeah with nobody
on it
I said maybe some rats and some workers
and how long does it take for a rat
population to cannibalize itself how
long can they live out there roaches you
know I mean how long can roaches survive
on a ship just floating around
who knows I feel like who knows I'm from
Florida
roaches can live for [ __ ] ever yeah I
mean they can live you can cut their
heads off they'll live for about couple
and they'll still live for a couple
weeks if that doesn't give you
nightmares I don't know what well they
can eat but it is true and they could
eat paint they paint they like the glue
that holds books matters together
yeah she'll eat anything so if you have
a if you have a ship floating around
there's just no ecosystem really other
than what's in that ship
how long can how long can a population
of roaches survive it's a creepy idea
eternally I don't know forever
I feel like eventually they'll run out
like I said I grew up in Florida I know
from Britt and I'm not talking about
this little bitty German cockroach I'm
gonna tase a little bit like look at my
camera I'm not talking about these are
like this big now according to my
understanding about the ghost ships
because there have been other ghost
ships out on the ocean there was like a
Chinese one that was sighted a couple
times and they think it's gone now what
ends up happening is after about 15 20
years most of them sink what you would
think that would happen after yeah the
hull can only remain in - it can only
maintain its integrity for only so long
yeah I mean eventually they sink or they
run aground - was the other thing that
happens to them yeah but not on the
Great Lakes you know if it runs aground
then people see it because I think
there's pretty much the cat is biting
the tripod I told you I understand it
because around the Great Lakes
you know the coastline of the Great
Lakes I think is pretty pretty much
well-traveled I yeah so if it ran
aground you'd see it it's just it's just
bizarre although one thing I want to
mention is that there's apparently a
wreck in the Great Lakes like underneath
the water a wreck of the SS Kamloops and
this particular rack is sent to house
I'm not sure if it's a ghost or visit
actual dead body
but they call it grandpa and it's
supposedly a preserved body that was
left in the engine room and like when
divers go down there to explore the
wreck they have reported that they'll be
like farting around like in another part
of the ship and all of a sudden this
little corpse Oh like pop up behind him
like hey what's up right so I don't know
if this corpse is actually like [ __ ]
around like I was like floating all
around the ship or if it's like a ghost
type situation on the rope I bye but
it's happened so often that they've
named it grandpa I don't know he's
supposedly like a preserved corpse that
was from this particular because even if
it was really cold eventually it's eaten
by the creatures that are there yeah you
would think that even down even down at
the bottom where the Titanic is all the
bodies are going there well you see the
shoes yeah where they work but they were
all eaten and it's cold there you know
it's damn near freezing and way down
towards the bottom you'll and still live
yes I'm cold that's why though this
sounds like [ __ ] to me that
particular story just saying I just
liked that one because I like the idea
of like a diver just stuff and then
there's like a little old man there's a
little smaller behind you hey the
problem with the story is that there's
little small bacterial type you know I
mean single cell and multi-celled
organisms down there you never the eat
[ __ ] you know I mean there's you know
the ocean version little bitty fish ya
know they eat that nature nature nature
takes nature takes care of that yeah
everybody eats like you know the only
except here is you're a human but also
your meat now if he was in a compartment
that was somehow sealed but still water
got in there but then how would he be
like floating around like I said there's
like a supernatural component sounds
like a tall tale but this like I said
this kind of ties in with the whole goes
phillipe kind of legend about the great
league because like I said when I looked
it up there's a lot of [ __ ] ghost
stories about the gray so there's a lot
of haunted lighthouses too but I didn't
get into that
because it was too many you know what I
mean too many yeah there's like two
there was too many stories it's like I
don't even get into the whole like they
there's like a dog man like werewolf
type legend there's like a black dog of
Lake Erie's like I kind of kind of look
[ __ ] legends I didn't mention the
like there was a Nessie type situation
going on there too but maybe we'll do
the creatures on another show yeah cuz
there was there's too much cuz we gotta
wrap this [ __ ] up we're getting here
we're getting super drunk in the kitty
kitty is also like trying to like [ __ ]
with the camera yeah she's like I said
you can't see her but she's sitting back
there behind the van going alright so
we're gonna wrap this show up hopefully
it wasn't too incoherent not gonna be
good I guess I'll find out what I
understand I guess I'll find out what I
edited yeah drive a truck out no no
we're you know if you're just sitting at
your house it's like something straight
out of Merv Griffin elevator killing now
every time you see my girlfriend I'm
gonna yeah yeah we did yeah pretty much
alright so if you like the show remember
like share subscribe and all your social
media if you'd like to financially
support show you can go to our patreon
page patreon.com/lenguin
com and there's a link in the sidebar
where you can give money through PayPal
if you'd rather do that give it one up
one-time donation you give monthly
donation you're doing everyone if you
much appreciate it whatever it is that
you do also remember that our regular
episodes come out every Tuesday we also
have movie retrospectives which come out
every Friday and we also have 13 o'clock
matinee which is three movies in the
theater and new ones and that comes out
every Sunday little capsule movie
reviews that we do right there in the
theater comes out every Sunday like I
said so check those out check out our
last movie retrospective which is liu
chuwu full cheese
city of the Living Dead and that will do
it for episode 131 we will see you next
time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]